laura ingram had a story called the  biden who stole christmas  sean hannity then ran an almost  identical story called the grinch who  stole christmas but there's a picture of  joe biden in a green suit and tie  yesterday morning there was a segment on  unfiltered with dan bongino that might  be a fox news online show maybe it's an  actual tv show on the weekends i don't  know  the segment was called how the biden  administration is stealing christmas  aaron rupar reported on thursday last  week that fox news mentioned christmas  at least 106 times in the prior 24 hours  this is sort of like the epitome  of the cultural replacing the  substantive for the american right wing